for at least the third time this year
Greek life at a major American
University is suspended following the
depth of eternity pledge Andrew Coffey a
20 year old Florida State University
freshman died Friday morning he was
found unresponsive after an off-campus
party the death is still under
investigation but the university
president didn't wait to take action
Manuel Bojorquez is in Tallahassee right
outside the pi Kappa Phi fraternity
house where coffee was pledging Manuel
good morning good morning students here
at FSU are still digesting the news both
of Andrew coffees death and of President
John thrashers decision to indefinitely
suspend all 55 fraternities and
sororities 22% of the school's
undergrads are reportedly part of a
Greek organization that's more than
7,500 students I think it could be a
little bit of a wake-up call so I kind
of spread like awareness students had
mixed feelings about the Greek
suspension on Monday it really wasn't
the fault of all the other fraternities
while some thought the action was too
drastic the university president felt it
appropriate in light of Friday's death
we just wish we could have saved this
individual sometimes an accident nothing
we can do about that but this is
something we've got at address
Tallahassee police have not determined
the exact cause of Andrew Coffey's death
but they say there are indicators that
alcohol was involved
unfortunately when medical emergency
personnel got here along with TPD they
determined the person to be deceased
in a statement pi Kappa Phi the
fraternity coffee was pledging four when
he died said the members of the chapter
have been directed to cooperate fully
with all investigative efforts
it's obviously not just a problem for
Florida State it's a problem for just
about every major University earlier
this year
authorities at Penn State suspended
Greek social activities for the spring
semester following the hazing death of
19 year old Timothy Piazza in September
the death of 18-year old Maxwell groover
led Louisiana State University to issue
a one-month Greek suspension back here
at Florida State President Thrasher says
he'll end the suspension when Greek
organizations help create a new culture
for students
my hope is that it's not gonna be long I
hope that they'll come in with some
ideas we have some ideas and it will
come to an agreement real quickly
in the meantime Greek organizations here
at FSU will be prohibited from holding
new member meetings chapter meetings and
even participating in next week's
homecoming students will still be
allowed to live in fraternity and
sorority houses but any violations of
the ban will result in disciplinary
action Gail thank you very much Manuel